Vous vous souvenez qu'il y a quelque temps, je vous avais proposé, pour fêter les 200 000 abonnés, de vous envoyer un cadeau...
J'avais créé pour ça un formulaire, sur lequel vous répondiez et après vous envoyiez un courrier.
Alors oui, on a reçu quelques lettres, hein...
Voilà, on a reçu ça, on a reçu ça, on a reçu bien sûr tout ça là, ça c'est un carton qui est rempli de lettres également...
Les courriers vont être envoyés à partir de demain.
Et j'ai pas encore ouvert toutes les lettres...
Parce qu'il y a beaucoup trop de lettres.
Par contre, en les ouvrant, on commence à trouver des choses !
Alors Mélanie, qui s'est tapé les 2000 premières ouvertures,
m'a mis de côté tous vos mots, et je crois qu'il y a des cadeaux aussi,
et je vais découvrir ça, là, maintenant !
Alors bien sûr, je pourrai pas lire les lettres de tout le monde à la caméra,
mais je les lirai toutes, ça c'est sûr.
Ça prendra un petit peu de temps, mais c'est tellement cool de recevoir du courrier...
Alors, déjà on a du fan art : ça c'est moi, ça c'est Tamalo (qui est devenu un chat-loup), ou Va(che)nille, c'est au choix.
Oh, Black Stories, trop fort ! Alors ça c'est le Black Stories "Morts de rire", que je n'ai pas;
alors la personne qui m'a envoyé ça - excuse-moi, j'ai pas ton nom sous les yeux, y'a pas la petite étiquette avec,
mais déjà merci; et dans toutes les vidéos que je tourne chez moi (dans le bureau qu'il y a chez moi, à côté de la bibliothèque)
il y a un Black Stories, parce que j'adore ce jeu, et ça c'est la version "Morts de rire", que je ne connais pas,
mais merci parce que en fait, à la base, c'est moi qui suis sensé vous envoyer un petit cadeau, en plus...
Et là je reçois apparemment des gros trucs...
Genre "Invisible" de Damien Savina.
Damien, c'est un grand magicien, c'est un grand créateur,
et j'ai eu la surprise immense en ouvrant une des lettres, de voir un petit mot avec ça,
où il y avait marqué "Il n'y a pas de raison qu'il n'y ait que toi qui fasses des cadeaux",
et il m'a envoyé un superbe numéro (qu'il a créé)
de bagues volantes. Merci beaucoup Damien, merci !
Et là tout le monde se dit "Quoi, on peut faire voler des bagues, mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?!"
Du chocolat Suisse; alors les Suisses, vous avez eu un point commun :
vous m'avez envoyé beaucoup de chocolats, et beaucoup d'argent...
Trop d'argent ! Il faut arrêter d'envoyer de l'argent !
C'est-à-dire qu'au départ on trouvait des 50 centimes, après on a trouvé des 1 euros et des 2 euros
(c'était pour acheter les timbres retour).
Alors ça c'est très compliqué en fait, parce que vous imaginez :
on a reçu 7000 lettres (7500 lettres là, pour l'instant),
c'est compliqué d'aller acheter les timbres pour tout le monde.
Bref, on fait de notre mieux...Et on est montés aussi jusqu'à un billet de 20 euros.
Un billet de 20 balles, quand même !
Alors, le billet de 20, je l'ai remis dans une enveloppe, et j'ai marqué un mot à la personne en disant :
"Non, on va pas prendre les 20 euros", mais c'était... Parce que 20 euros pour un timbre, c'est beaucoup quand même, hein.
Je sais pas, en Suisse apparemment ça passe bien, mais...
Merci Mathilde, pour ce petit billet Mentalo !
Ça je sais pas comment je dois le prendre,
parce qu'on voit bien que c'est un pochoir, du coup c'est quoi le message -
c'est que si on faisait un pochoir avec moi en taille réelle, ça donnerait ça ?
Je suis trop petit, c'est ça ?
Je prends très mal ce dessin...
"Cher Fabien Olicard, je n'ai pas pu timbrer mon enveloppe, néanmoins vous trouverez ci-joint
un coupon-réponse, qui permettra de me renvoyer ma lettre. J'espère que ça suffira;
bien à vous,
Simon."
Écoute Simon, je ne sais pas, je vais découvrir ton coupon-réponse.
Rien que le mot "coupon-réponse", ça me paraît compliqué quand même...
Le petit cerf de Victor :
"Pourrais-tu mettre cette carte dans une de tes vidéos à venir, derrière toi par exemple ? Ça me ferait super plaisir."
Quelque chose me dit que là t'es bien servi !
Teeellement plaisir d'avoir autant de courrier...
"Mon palais mental" : wow !
Tu t'es créé un palais mental à base de trains, euh...
De trains...Comment on appelle ça... Comment on appelle ça, Mélanie ?
De trains... Non mais oui, non mais bien sûr ! *rires* Évidemment que c'est un train, mais tu sais, les...
Les petits... On dit pas un "petit train", c'est... Un train électrique, un train en modèle réduit, en fait.
Y'a pas un nom pour ça ?
Je sais pas si t'avais déjà ça, et que tu t'en es fait un palais mental, ou si t'avais commencé à construire le palais mental,
et du coup que tu es en train de le refaire en réel...
Quoi qu'il en soit, je trouve ça très drôle. Mais plutôt malin, aussi !
Oh, un livre aussi ! Alors ça c'est énorme aussi, attend, je crois qu'il y avait un petit mot avec...
J'ai reçu de la part de Yann, via Amazon, un bouquin d'énigmes.
Mais merci beaucoup Yann, déjà, merci !
"Qu'arrive-t-il, demanda Annabelle, si x détruit y lorsque x et y sont une seule et même expression
(en d'autres termes, supposons que x détruise x), cela signifie-t-il que le robot x se détruirait lui-même ?
C'est exactement ça, confirma Didier-Charles, ces robots sont appelés 'suicidaires'.
Alors maintenant sauriez vous trouver un robot x qui soit suicidaire?
mon système en prévoit un.
c'est évident dit Alexandre
Nous savons déjà trouvé un x tels que x crée x
donc Dx se détruira lui même
et bien non coupa Didier-Charles
si x se crée lui même alors Dx détruira x mais ça ne veut pas dire que Dx détruira Dx
et c'est pourtant ce qu'on cherche.
Ah oui bien sûr murmura Alexandre
Alors qu'elle est la solution correcte?
Voilà
donc je te remercie Yann
On va bien se marrer.
Je pense qu'on va faire juste cette énigme là durant tout 2017
Beaucoup d'origami,  Grifondor,
Joli truc joli
ça se trouve il y a des petits mots dedans que je  n'ai pas regardé
Quand je vous dis qu'on trouve de l'argent.
2euros50 de scotché
Un mini jeu de carte en porte clé, c'est pas énorme ça aussi.
"Salut désolé pas de timbre français en Belgique je t'ai mis de quoi les payer. Merci. Adrien"
Apparemment pas de papier chez toi donc du coup tu déchires des livres
Impeccable
Dis donc c'est bien dégueulasse ça, il faut que je fasse voir ça, quand même, à un psy
Très étrange de me faire ce dessin là
"Pour toi Fabien Olicard, continue tes vidéos"
Alors, écoutes,
*rire*
Déjà, je voulais te remercier, toi qui m'as fait ce cadeau
Je me suis dis c'est peut être un chapeau mais même pas en fait
C'est...
[Mélanie lui parle]
Aah il y avait les 20 euros dedans. D'accord. C'est là qu'il y avait les 20 balles
Ok. Donc les 20 euros, que l'on m'avait envoyé, était là dedans, d'accord
et... et en plus de ça, alors ça c'est toujours très désastreux pour mon ego
c'est à dire que tu as réussi à faire 2 fautes d'orthographe dans mon nom de famille
c'est à dire que tu as mis 2 L au lieu d'un et pas de D
C'est... voilà, bon je te re...
[S'adressant à Mélanie] En fait on va garder les 20 euros
Merci beaucoup d'avoir envoyé tous ces petits mots et ces petits cadeaux
C'était pas le but. A la base je vous demandais juste un enveloppe
pour vous glisser votre cadeau
et vous l'envoyer
Vous avez été très très nombreux à m'envoyer ça. Merci beaucoup
Vous avez aussi été très très nombreux à m'envoyer des mails
et des commentaires, des tweets, des messages sur Facebook
pour savoir si vous aviez encore le temps
pour poser des questions sur le cadeau
pour plein de choses comme ça.
J'ai répondu à aucun.
Voilà.
Ca c'est dit... Aucun parce que
vraiment on a eu dix mille inscrits
pour le jeu
donc j'ai reçu
peut-être cinq mille, six mille messages comme ça
me posant des questions. J'avais essayé d'être le plus clair possible
désolé si il y en a qui ont vu que dernièrement
dans leurs spams le mail que j'avais envoyé
ou d'autres qui n'ont pas pu envoyer la lettre avant
Il fallait forcément
que je pose des limites puisque sinon je ne m'en sortais pas de mon côté.
Ca a été un taf énorme de mettre tout ça en place
Il nous reste un taf énorme pour tout renvoyer
Du coup ceux qui l'auront ça sera un collector, ça c'est sûr.
Je vous l'ai dit on fait les envois à partir de demain.
Dans vos enveloppes vous allez recevoir des choses qui ressemble un petit peu à ça
Et un petit peu à ça...
J'ai fait le plus vite possible car je sais que vous allez faire arrêt sur image.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère
que ça vous a plus, si c'est le cas
likez
abonnez-vous
et rendez-vous demain à 17h. Ciao !